all right Alex yes Alex so where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
I'm from Fontana California
and tell me about your family so my
family is pretty uh conservative I grew
up Christian and
um growing up I was just like uh this is
not for me but it's kind of like a
forced practice growing up so it kind of
caged in everything else that was
naturally myself and which brings me to
say that I believe I was born gay like
I'm a naturally a gay man but you know
in my background it's just like I
couldn't explore it you know I didn't
know what it was your family didn't
approve exactly you know the word gay
wasn't even mentioned in the household
so
it was replaced with the word confusion
which even furthered my confusion as you
know I explored my sexuality or I wanted
to know more of like why my body reacted
to certain things on a man or what a man
did right
how would you describe your childhood in
general
um pretty average only seasoned with the
bullying of course like again I didn't
know what gay was but clearly people
around me did and when they saw how
effeminate I was or my
feminine characteristics I was easily
like the target you know and it wasn't
just me it was sadly other guys like me
but who didn't know who they were so it
was just like a gay Witch Hunt right
holdy I'm 29 29.
what kind of cute we do in high school
oh gosh I was always the theater kid I
loved singing in choir
um it just made me feel free
and it just made me feel like I had a
voice amongst peers who were similar to
me
and you've had jobs since in school oh
yeah absolutely I started working as a
event host in Anaheim I was you know in
charge of birthday parties and stuff
like that so
the hospitality industry has always been
the industry I worked in for a while
because of my personality because
when you're a natural gay man people
want to
you know gravitate around your charisma
so you have an interesting is it a
fetish you would call it or what would
you call it I would say a fetish yeah a
fetish it's kind of something that turns
me on how do you describe it uh
voyeurism uh yeah yeah
um or gay cruising to those who aren't
familiar but I mean there's probably
more
uh
established ways of doing that yeah but
your your way is a little
um uh not so established
describe how you go about this well gosh
it's just like so of course when you
have the natural need to
use the restroom you go and you know
being a gay man obviously I'm attracted
to other men but in these instances
let's say going to a restroom there are
no partitions at the urinals and you
know you're focusing on yourself but on
that off chance you look to the right or
the left and
you're seeing another man's member and
something about it is like you know
he has a he has a penis like me
but some are different some look better
and
just another man's penis is
it just gets my arousal going
and for some reason while it when I'm
there it's just like
I'm in the zone
you know it's just a fire kicks in is it
because it's
not it's like forbidden you don't you
don't yeah yeah it's not like meeting a
guy in a club who's ready to go and it's
a little more
it's a more forbidden uh interaction
exactly
um
like they don't know it at first I don't
know it at first it's kind of it just
happens naturally if it were to happen
um because in regards to that there are
cases when other guys can kind of pick
up that same energy you're giving off if
you're curious about so if you're
looking at somebody's yeah
what they're doing they can probably
sense that you're looking yeah exactly
exactly I can backfire on you I'm sure
it can so it's just like
you have to stay still
to make sure you're you don't trigger
anyone else
and
the only time it becomes enjoyable is
when you let the other person kind of
make a move
and so
just as I'm describing it yeah it sounds
more predatory or kind of like more
primal
but at the same time
it's interesting because you find out
that
I'm not the only one
you know
but yeah give me an example of how these
interactions go well oh okay
so let's say yeah
you're in the bathroom at your urinal
you know handling your business but then
let's say a guy you're an old
a couple steps away from you on the
right doing the same thing but
most guys tend to when they want to fool
around without getting caught as well
they'll technically like take a step
back
um or really let their member be fully
exposed
um I wish I could describe that in more
detail but
um and so when you give a glance you
just look and you're like okay so you
just continue to play with yourself
um but you look from your periphery
Vision you don't just like make it
obvious
and um like basically the lingering
happens so if you linger and the other
person lingers then
that's when the cruising begins
and that leads to what
um typically we just look at each other
or we just look at each other's members
for like a couple minutes or let's say
if we want to really
take something the next step further
we're just like okay let's just get out
of here and go somewhere else well
and how often do you do this
um
it's funny because I guess only when
I'm like I'm by myself
doing day-to-day things or I'm at
certain events
and I do it by myself so that way I
don't compromise others like if I'm out
with family or friends
but I actually as I'm getting older I
actually want to do it way less often I
actually want to stop even because I
have other things to focus on as I get
older and more responsibilities to
handle and plus I'd rather meet men a
different way sure you know that's not
how you want to view anyone I don't
think yeah exactly maybe for a quick
sexual interaction but not anything more
than that yeah exactly
how often does this go badly when you
get curious in the men's room
um only a few times it's just like you
you have to really know your surrounding
know your atmosphere
um and like and like I said not to sound
like I'm some expert at it but it's just
like when you really keep to yourself
and don't cause a scene I think that's
what would trigger things to go wrong
has this ever turned into anything more
than just a quick little
oh yeah oh yeah but I typically would
take it elsewhere or the gentleman and I
we would go to like a hotel or somewhere
else
yeah so the the gay male Community is a
very different
Community sexually than any other I
think absolutely you guys are
it's a free-for-all for you guys very
often right yes and the thing about it
is it's just like because our community
has unfortunately been so compacted into
certain sections into certain venues and
so on it's like
our huge Primal is instincts like
everyone else's gets shrinked and so
when you kind of shrink the beast in a
cage
it rattles even more
and do you feel like this behavior is
something you're you're not proud of and
you would like to stop you mentioned
you'd like to do it less
you know even though it does arouse me
um yeah a more mature part of myself
especially in this day and age wants to
decrease that activity because yeah I
want to focus more on meeting men
emotionally than physically first
um only because I feel like a lot of
people are getting detached emotionally
or energetically so I want to get back
to that something more authentic exactly
and because I know the physicality will
come and I've had my fun I've had my
enjoyments so I'm not it'd be nice to
have both yeah
exactly and it's not likely you'll get
both exactly
and so how is your family now with you
being gay have they accepted it or
it's still something that is like it's
like we know he's gay but we most likely
won't talk about it
yeah the world has come a long way but
we still have a long way to go I think
yeah yeah what's been the hardest part
of of this lifestyle for you being gay
ah well in Los Angeles it's much more
accepted and it's no big deal
well on the flip side of that we deal
with issues in the community as well we
deal with colorism racism uh having
preferences of body types uh
uh mannerisms it's like we've basically
marginalized ourselves somehow and now
it's just like it's made
interacting even harder so
there are times when my sexuality or my
physical urges would go Sky High because
it's like no I really need that need met
but it's just like
the emotion it just the emotional needs
get pushed to the side because everyone
else is focusing on the physicality
first
hmm
what do you wish was different about the
gay community
oh just that we even though the outside
world may not show us as much love like
I would love for us to show each other
that love we're looking for you know we
have to start with ourselves and then
start with each other because that's
what we're really needing you know and
like I said we need to
teach ourselves to be more like comrades
more like authentic friends and then
teach each other or learn from different
mentors on how to be actual romantic
partners and not just sexual partners
yeah that would be great
where would you like to see your life go
in the future you're still a young man
oh gosh I definitely see myself I
actually want to live abroad somewhere
in Europe I want to be in like an energy
healer and I also want to publish books
and be a linguist so I would like to
interpret different languages for
different people
oh that's great
do you have any regrets in your life
I have a couple of regrets
um one that I'll say uh
there was a boy at prom
and we I guess we didn't have like a
falling out but we had stopped talking
our Junior and Senior year
um in this particular gentleman I
I loved him I think it was like a crush
Beyond a crush and
I I wanted that MTV moment where I you
know I'm at prom I'm looking for someone
I really really care for and I just
wanted to get the chance to tell him
that you know I love you before we never
see each other again
but you never do
never did I couldn't find him
and Alex what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
important most important lesson is to
keep going you've got to persevere you
know
um even when the times are tough
it's usually those times that actually
mowed you into the better person that
you're becoming
excellent Alex thank you so much for
sharing your story absolutely I wish you
lots of luck in your future of course
Mark you bet you thank you very much